a grassroots effort begins to grow a las
vegas man seeks help from the community
to collect school supplies for students
in need
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how he's giving back and the
inspiration behind it
working really hard as a team as a
school to figure everything out daniela
silverstein adjusts to a new normal
teaching online is a whole new thing
bringing challenges for the kindergarten
teacher at john s
park elementary school things that we
totally don't think about
are new things that we think about that
includes school supplies for her
students at home during distance
education
students are doing specials online so pe
art music all that stuff they don't have
paint they don't have paint brushes
jump ropes bean bags just anything to
participate really
but her friend brandon johnson wants to
help silverstein says he responded to
her social media post
about the issues last week and is taking
the initiative to aid
educators they gave me the opportunity
to help kids
pencils colors he's starting a donation
drive
no name just a mission help the kids
some of these parents can't afford it
he's partnering with businesses and
churches around the valley
to take these large gray bins we want to
make it as easy as possible for people
to donate so i ultimately want 50 drop
spots across the city to keep it covered
safe all bins will be outside businesses
where anyone who wants to donate can
drop off supplies
and then walk away i will be personally
driving by each bin
to check each bin and collect them all
supplies going to park
elementary and miley achievement center
elementary school for students to pick
up and grab bags
this effort though may include more soon
ultimately i want to help anybody who
reaches out to me any teacher at any
school
giving students a chance to succeed this
year kristen drummond 8 news now
a wish list is also online for people
not comfortable leaving their homes
because of covid
for that list and bid locations as well
as drop off times
just visit our website eight newsnow dot
com